hello we're glad you joined us for this
live webinar may pair next-generation
sequencing as a powerful clinical tool
for the characterization of cancer I am
Christina Mahalo collaborate and I'll be
moderating this session today's
educational web seminar is presented by
the labyrinth the leading scientific
social networking website and provider
of our children's in webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning to
learn more visit Latrice calm let's get
started you can post questions to the
speaker during the presentation while
they're touching your mind to do so
simply type in in the Q&A box which will
open when you click on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window questions will be
answered after the presentation to
enlarge the site window click on the
screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you
experience technical problems seeing or
nearing the presentation just click on
the support button at the top right of
the presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the screen
this is an educational webinar and thus
offers free continuing education credits
after the webinar is over please click
on the seee button located in the bottom
left hand corner of your webpage that
follow the process of obtaining your
credit I now present today's speaker
David Smith PhD professor in consultant
at Mayo Clinic David Smith received his
BS in mathematics in molecular biology
from the University of Wisconsin in
Madison she then received his PhD for
from for the department of biochemistry
also at the University of Wisconsin in
Madison
after several postdoctoral positions he
got his first academic appointment at
Wayne State University in 1996 he joined
the Mayo Clinic in the Department of
Laboratory Medicine in pathology as
professor and consultant she was also
appointed as the head of the cancer
genetics program for the Mayo Clinic
cancer center his research focuses on
the role of the common fragile size
play in cancer development she is
lavatory also works on the various roles
that too that if human papilloma virus
plays in development of different
cancers subject Smith is also the
chairman of the technology assessment
risk for the Mayo Clinic Center for
individualized medicine the
responsibility of this group is to
evaluate new technologies for their
potential impact on research in its
clinical translation his laboratory
utilizes next-generation sequencing to
characterize the molecular alterations
that occur during the development of
cancer they also have been using the
powerful technique of make paired
next-generation sequencing in PC to
characterize the fiscal status of HPV
in different HPV driven cancers dr.
Smith will now begin his presentation
thank you Christina it's a pleasure to
be here today again I'm going to be
talking about MAPE air next-generation
sequencing and why I believe this could
be a very powerful clinical tool for the
management of cancer patients all of
this starts with next-generation
sequencing which are technologies which
are based upon massively parallel
sequencing one runs hundreds of
thousands to billions of simultaneous
sequencing reactions and what differs
are the various technologies that a
unified utilize to perform the actual
sequencing the very first viable
next-generation sequencing was developed
by a company called for five four life
sciences and this is a picture of the
actual sequencing box where the
sequencing and the chemistry is done in
the white box and the top little screen
with the TV is where you can monitor
everything that is occurring the key of
all types of first generation
next-generation sequencing was to figure
a way to amplify individual DNA
molecules to a sufficient number of
molecules so that one can get a
sufficient signal for the sequencing of
that individual molecule and the four
five four platform utilizes something
which is known as a motion PCR to
produce that clonal amplification the
key features of this emulsion PCR is the
fact that you are making individual
little reaction vesicles which are tiny
little water droplets in a liquid
interface and what one does is in these
tiny little droplets that only contain
maybe 50 pika liters of water you are
actually placing several things the
first is a bead which is shown as the
little bead on the top right hand corner
the second is an individual DNA fragment
and the third is the necessary reagent
to amplify that DNA fragment and the
fourth are all of the nucleotides on the
surface of the bead and what one does is
one does a very dilute concentration of
these beads individual DNA analysis so
that you're not amplifying multiple DNA
molecules in an individual bead and at
the end of emulsion PCR were in that
bead where you had a single DNA molecule
you were able to amplify that DNA
molecule up to
1 million copies and the second thing is
- and so if one goes through the entire
process one takes your DNA source that
could be an entire genome or a portion
of the genome and those DNA fragments
are those DNA is cut into fragments and
the fragments have primers we could call
them a and B that are placed on the
honest on the 5-prime and 3-prime end of
those fragments and then the individual
fragments at a very dilute concentration
are placed into the emulsion PCR to
amplify an individual fragment so where
there was once an original fragment
there's up to 1 million one has a very
dilute concentration of that so that
there's no more than one DNA fragment
amplified per feed since the majority
that these have no DNA fragments they
don't amplify any DNA but one can purify
the fragments with amplified DNA from
the ones that do not on an some type of
density gradient one once one has taken
that and has basically broken the
emulsions you can take the individual
beads and place it into the sequencing
surface which is actually a Pico titer
plate it's called a Pico titer plate
because it holds Pico leader volume and
it's actually produced from a
telecommunication cable which basically
has one and a half million very thin
fibers whose diameter is 30 microns the
diameter the beads on this platform is
28 microns and then when one place is
that in and shown on the extreme right
is the bead with the necessary or
reagents for the PCR meant for the PCR
for the sequencing and it utilizes pyro
sequencing which can detect the
incorporation of the nucleotides by the
release of light so then one place
effete into the machine then has four
different containers that contain
individual nucleotides these nucleotides
are naked they have nothing on them
they're not blocked in any way one
floods this with a and a switch of the
weld produces a signal through
pyrosequencing which is a light reaction
that's one sided with T G and C and then
one continues this as one is
incorporating bases on the next slide
one can see the same picture again and
the actual outputs on the sequence of a
single bead so you can see that the very
first base incorporated with the T
when when one cycle of all four bases
tcga the tea was incorporated then one
dozen cycle again for the next base and
you can see it to see however you can
see that some of the peaks are higher
you see where you have two A's they
incorporated because the bases are not
blocked one incorporates both days if
there are two teams that require an a to
be incorporated further over you can see
the incorporation of four G's so this is
the output from a single B from the
first generation of this machine and you
have 191 base pair read very quickly
they were able to get the read length
even longer now the strengths and
weaknesses of this platform was there
was the birth of next generation
sequencing it was capable of doing long
sequence read length that was not much
shorter than Sanger and this was a real
strength and it transformed sequencing
the predecessor to the 45-foot platform
was Sanger sequencing which was actually
utilized for sequencing the human genome
at a cost of over 200 million dollars
for sequencing and yet in 1998 along the
it developed for 5'4 platform this
sequence of Jim Watson his whole genome
the sequence for cost was only 1 million
dollars which is a transformation in
terms of the total cost for genome
sequencing but there are notable see
there are notable weaknesses to this
platform one was a limited room for
improvement the first generation machine
was capable of 28 20 mega bases of
sequence with improvement they were able
to improve that to 500 mega bases per
run and this is the how the Watson
genome was sequenced but there was no
room for further improvement they
couldn't get Wheatlands greater and you
couldn't have a larger number of beads
because that's all the microtiter plate
could hold the second real weakness was
the emulsion PCR which is an extremely
messy technique and difficult to do and
the third already mentioned is this
whole homo polymer issue if you have a
long string of nucleotides they are all
incorporated because the bases are not
blocked if one wants to utilize this in
a clinical sequencing setting there are
a number of positions in the human and
other genomes as well that have long
words of homopolymers and it is very
difficult to discern the difference
between for example 10 nucleotides be
incorporated in 11 and so it's going to
be sequence at in accuracy at those
positions the second survival sequencing
platform to be developed
was a missus from the company called
Illumina which was actually purchased
from a company called Alexa their first
generation machine was the Illumina
genome analyzer and this one the bottom
is the actual reference from nature of
this sequencing platform the Illumina
genome analyzer had a number of notable
advantages and improvements over the
four five four the first was an
improvement as a way to amplify DNA
rather than have DNA fragments that were
amplified in emotion one places on the
surface of something which is known as a
flow cell the same types of nucleotides
one could call them a and B the DNA
fragments are then produced the same way
as on the 454 and one flows the DNA
fragments across the flow cell and what
happens is that DNA fragment the primary
one and is complementary to one of the
primers there's a high density of
primers on the flow surface to them and
then the other end is complementary to
the orange which is now on the surface
and what can happen is that DNA fragment
can bend over and now you produce
basically a DNA fragment that is now
bridged and hence this is known as
bridge amplification and the presence of
polymerase this DNA fragment can be
copied so that you can basically now
have two copies if you do nature that
now you have two copies at that position
and one can repeat this process and by
the time you're finished where there was
an individual DNA fragment now you have
30,000 DNA fragments which is sufficient
for this platform for the detection of
signal this flow cell can then be taken
from the machine where it is produced
and placed into the sequencing machine
the top right actually shows the first
generation of how these these clusters
were actually done and how good job
qualification was done and now on the
surface of the flow cell where you had
individual DNA molecules you now have
these clusters but across the surface of
this slow cell there were millions of
these clusters this flow cell is then
taken and placed into the sequencing
machine and in the sequencing machine
you can then basically do sequencing and
a second advantage of this platform is
instead of having unboxed nucleotides
the nucleotides themselves are
fluorescently labeled g1 color C another
T and other and a and other and then one
can do
all four of the incorporation
simultaneously rather than flowing one
at a time one adds the nucleotides and
at in the presence of a primer for
sequencing one will incorporate and
avail the nucleotide at each position
and you can see in the middle there's
one base one cluster that gets a chain
one get the T one get to see among gets
an A one thing to picture that and the
top right is the picture of the flow
cell and the corporation's of each
position after that is done the only a
single base can be done because the
fluorescence blocks the nucleotides from
incorporating another base but in the
presence of something to remove the
fluorescent nucleotide now that base
that is capable of adding a second base
and you can do repeat the process and
then you take a picture there that is
shown in the top right to the second
panel then you see the third the fourth
and the fifth and if one takes a look
for example at the sequence of the
cluster on the left the first base
incorporated to G then achieve and
achieve and achieve in MA that GC TGA is
the sequence of that single cluster and
one does this simultaneously for
hundreds of thousands of individual
fragments however the original Illumina
sequencing machines three years after
was developed the new machine came out
and this was the high C 2000 once they
realize that the slow cell has two
processes a chemistry process and a
scanning process they realize that they
should probably have to slow so one that
does the chemistry the second that
that's the scanning and the high C 2000
was capable of running two slides to
flow cells rather than a single one and
the improvements on the high C the first
thing is when clusters were originally
made the the clusters actually occur on
the top and the bottom of the slide but
the original sequencer only read and had
a focal plane at the top but now they
were able to have focal planes at the
top and the bottom which doubled the
number of possible sequences there was a
faster scanning of slides it was capable
of longer read length and greater number
of clusters per slide but very quickly
this obsoleted the genome analyzer with
less than a three year life cycle and
this is a disadvantage especially when
each individual machine costs just shy
of 700,000
now if you look to the bottom right one
sees that the undefined features when
you have random spacing when you use
these flow cells and you just randomly
amplify amplify clusters this worked
quite well and increased output on this
main machine went up at least one
hundredfold but eventually you reach a
point where it becomes very difficult to
discern one amplified cluster from
another and what happened is the next
advanced was known as the pattern flow
so Amisha shown on the bottom left
rather than just have a slide surface
and random amplification there are
amplifications that are occurring in
these pattern flow cells each individual
little dimple is its individual place
where single molecule can be amplified
and when one sees the picture this is
shown in the bottom middle you get much
more ordered spacing which makes it much
easier to tell one sequence from another
and gives you the capability of
producing a higher density higher
density means there are more sequences
across the flow cell which means greater
sequence output and then what one has an
entire space of different sequences from
Illumina and this is actually an old
slide which actually because there's a
new platform that has come out but at
the bottom left is the lower output
machine which is the my seat this
machine produces 15 Giga bases of
sequence 25 million reads by producing
300 base pair reads at the ends of
fragments one should realize that the
original sequences from Illumina was
capable it's only a single Giga base of
output and the read length on the
original machine was only 30 base pairs
which made it very difficult to assign
where those fragments were in the genome
there was a second platform that had a
greater output of 120 gigabases the high
seek 2500 which was a one terabyte of
sequence output and then the first
viable machine that was utilizing the
pattern flow cells is the high CG X 10
which produce 1.8 tera bases of sequence
6 billion sequences on basically 2 x 150
base pair reads at the ends of the
fragments and these machines were very
powerful but you had to purchase 10 of
these machines at a time that it cost us
10 million dollars however
they're the strengths and weakness's
platform are really important one is
currently the lowest cost for base for
sequencing of any sequencing platform
and it is the only viable platform for
whole genome sequencing however I should
mention that BGI the Beijing genome
Institute does have the sequencing
platform that is made commercially
available could be a second platform
that is a viable platform for whole
genome sequencing currently Illumina
completely controls the sequencing space
they have blocked nucleotides which
means there is no home or polymer
problem but there are weaknesses to this
platform these high throughput machines
need sufficient sample or you're wasting
space if you turn the machine on and
turn the key you are utilizing the full
cost of the reagent systems about
$25,000 if you do not have enough
sequences on that machine then that cost
per sequencing goes up in this edition
there's a trouble with small amounts of
input nucleic acids if you have a
limiting amount of nucleic acids for
example from clinical samples it may be
difficult to get signals from those
limiting nucleic acids the customer
service is a potential problem because
with the absence of sufficient
competition there's really no motivation
for Illumina to have ultimate customer
service and because the customers really
don't have a choice if you want to do
whole genome sequencing this is the
platform you have to work on the second
one already mentioned is each time you
have a single platform the instrument
cycle time is relatively short which
means very quickly a new machine comes
out which obsolete all the machines that
you have and one other question one of
the goals of genome sequencing was to
make it affordable so affordable that it
could be routinely used and the thought
was that that should be a thousand
dollar genome but I suggest what about
the hundred dollar genome and could that
be achieved on this platform there's
really no motivation for Illumina to
push to get lower sequence because if
they do not have competition however
recently Illumina announced a new
platform and this is the Novus seek 6000
which is the newest generation machine
there are actually two machines and only
seek 5,000 and the 6000 the advantage on
these machines is is shown on the next
slide these machines actually have
flexible flow so that one can run
currently or soon to be available is the
0.5 tera base flow cell and the one tera
base flow cell and this gives you
greater output than you could have on
the previous platform and since the Nova
seeks 6000 actually runs to slow zones
with the one terabyte slow so you run
this machine you produce Tutera bases of
sequence soon to be released presumably
the end of 2017 early 2018 are to higher
throughput of flow cells one with two
Tara bases of sequencing one with three
Tara bases of sequencing with the three
Tara base flow cell and running an over
66,000 when you turn this machine on you
are producing six tera bases of sequence
output which is four times greater than
the high seek extent on the high seek
extend the cost to sequence in general
just the sequencing was less than $900
with this platform and four times the
output one reduces that even greater and
one starts to see an approach towards
even cheaper genome sequencing now there
is another platform and this is a
platform that is very similar to the 454
and it's not surprising because it was
developed by the same person who was
responsible for developing the 454
sequencing platform Jonathan Rosberg and
very similar to the 4 5 4 this has the
same type of amplification emulsion PCR
the bases are unblocked so they has the
same issue that the homopolymers are a
problem and while this platform came out
after Illumina it's been trying to play
catch-up to Illumina but it's not
working the Illumina platform which has
much greater output and has certain
advantages over the Ion Torrent platform
and anything the ayat or I can do a
Lumina can also do and this represents
at best and incremental technology and
still Illumina completely controls the
sequencing space however there are some
strengths to the Ion Torrent platform
the first is turnaround time this is a
faster sequencer to produce sequence and
it has a lower input amount of DNA which
is necessary for selection protocols so
if one is doing sequencing of a small
gene panel for example one can use is
smaller amounts of input DNA and there
also this the national cancer is to
chose the sequencing platform the PGM
which is the personal genome sequencer
from them over the aluminum I see
because of this one fact and indeed
there are a number of clinical labs that
are adopting this platform because they
can get results from a higher proportion
of samples specially samples that have
small amounts of material
there's also viable solutions to
simplify emotion PCR because as
mentioned emotion PCR first generation
was much messier more difficult to do
than bridge amplification on the AI
instrument platform the Iron Chef is a
viable solution that makes it easier to
do without having to work with the
messiness of your hands of the lipids
and it has flexible output because on
the Ion Torrent platform it is capable
running multiple different sized things
depending on what you want to sequence
and this platform has the thought and
the strength that it could be further
improvement and indeed in the number of
years that the Ion Torrent platform has
come out it has increased its sequence
output dramatically it just hasn't been
able to get even close to the Illumina
platform
hence the ion torrent platform is not a
viable solution for genome sequencing
now and that raises the question will it
ever be available for that now there is
a next next-generation machine and this
is the first of that this is the path by
ORS backed by opus if of Biosciences has
now improved machine over this one this
is just an older picture this is the
first single molecule sequencing rather
than amplifying DNA fragments to a large
number of copies and then getting signal
from those multiple copies this machine
sequences single molecules and this has
certain strengths that I'll mention in a
minute this single molecule sequencing
does real-time sequencing by tethering a
DNA polymerase at the bottom of a tiny
little well which is known as a zero
mode waveguide this has fluorescently
colored nucleotides before base is a CG
and T and as each base is incorporated
through that form right fluorescence is
released and in the zero mode waveguide
which confines the wavelength of this
signal that's being released one can see
the output of an A and a T from two
sequences and this thing is a very fast
sequester because polymerase moves much
quicker than the slower chemistry's
the four or five four of the Illumina
platform however there's notable
weaknesses to this platform the accuracy
is only 85% this machine is so quick you
do not see every base that's
incorporated a second serious weaknesses
the output is low and it's been
relatively limited improvements since
becoming available now it has improved
at least one to two orders of magnitude
but unfortunately this is by far the
most expensive platform cost for bass
for sequencing now because of the
inaccuracy of sequencing there is the
use of smart bells these are the placing
of basically bells on the end of a DNA
fragment so the DNA is actually sequence
around and around so that what
interrogate the bases more than a single
time because the inaccuracies are
totally independent of base by
sequencing the same base multiple times
what can achieve the same sequence
accuracy as the other platforms but this
just decreases the output further and
also decreases the readlyn the strengths
of the pac file ever and these are
important is much longer read less with
the newest generation of Pacific
Biosciences machine average relent for
10,000 to 20,000 base pairs this is does
a viable instrument for completing
genome sequencing because one can use
this to scaffold together short sequence
reads from the other platforms and it's
also a very valuable thing for reading
the sequence of an entire transcript sub
RNA transcripts are considerably longer
than the sequence output capable on the
454 Illumina or the ion for a platform
and this can be used to sequence an
entire transcript and enables you to
determine exactly what the transcript is
and the difference between different
transcript isoforms since their long
reads that enables you to get through
difficult regions like the HLA fragile X
etc and PacBio used to be in partnership
with roast developing clinical assays
but earlier in 2016 Roche dropped the
PAC file which was a severe blow to pad
file as a viable sequencing platform and
having any clinical utility now there is
another viable single monitor sequencer
and this is from Oxford nanopore it
utilizes basically a variety of
different poor
which is a very small footprint so I'm
slightly larger than a USB memory card
and like the pack file this is a very
long read sequencer it uses fluorescent
detection of basis using different
strategies depending on which poor one
is utilizing and this is the actual
footprint of the Oxford nanopore
sequencer and this is a very important
thing because it's a portable sequencing
machine they utilize biological amount
of pores which are protein pores that
are naturally found in cell membranes
and with this and this is a picture of
this one type of pores this is a
solid-state metal core and on this one
you either can do the solid state or you
can use the biological metal cores but
one of the things that Silla straited
here is that not a single base at a time
goes through the pore actually on the
current Oxford nanopore there are six
bases in the pore at any one time and
but it's very difficult to know
definitively the sequence of that and
this has sequence accuracy very similar
to the Pat file so the strength is a
small footprint it's ideal as a portable
sequencer times it's useful in the field
or in space and indeed the Oxford
nanopore has been placed into space and
there's been some sequencing performed
in space because you don't need a very
heavy machine it can be carried and
there's been dramatic improvement since
this has first been made available the
weakness is is the accuracy is terrible
very similar to the back file and the
output still has a very long way to go
can they ever be viable to whole genome
sequencing and that is in question that
I do not know currently but it does not
look like in the next couple of years
and possibly the next five years that
this will be a machine where whole
genome sequencing can be done similar to
the SIB PacBio machine so there are
other next-generation sequencing
platforms I'm not doing this to mention
all of them but for example new bio the
sequencing by hybridization which is
potentially very promising for small
gene panels and a number of years ago I
believe two years ago this was purchased
by bio res kaijin has developed an
integrated end-to-end next generation
sequencing solution they have single
sided sequencing by synthesis but they
also have everything from sample
preparation
library preparation sequencing on their
sequence
machine and they purchased an analysis
company ingenuity so basically it's an
integrated solution for every six the
there's also DNA electronics DNA
electronics was owns the Ion Torrent
platforms Platt patents and they are an
easy platform for small genome panels
and they're currently developing a
sepsis test Genea is utilizing a
biological metaphor and planar
electronic sensors and indeed there are
many other platforms that are in
development now what are the impediments
to a new necessaries and sequencing
technology one of the serious impediment
suspend the Illumina platform which has
now been in circulation for 10 years if
made dramatic improvements have any new
platform that comes along that's just an
incremental improvement will not be
competitive so what is truly needed is a
real game-changer for example a platform
that can do whole genome sequencing for
$100 with a long reach technology that
is accurate currently this is merely a
pipe tree it would be really nice if
this was available or a very simple
platform for small gene panels that puts
together DNA isolation selection and
sequencing and it's quick accurate and
very cheap and this is the thought that
some of the things for example that I
mentioned on the previous life one of
these could possibly be this however
again it's one of these platforms comes
out and is merely incremental to what is
available for Illumina this is not going
to be viable once this type of
sequencing for example on the Illumina
platform is in clinical practice they
are very low to switch platforms unless
the platform is such a different such a
game-changer so again once something has
been adopted it is very difficult to
change now with the sequencing platforms
and again I'm going to discuss mainly
aluminum and ion turret there are
different types of next-generation
sequencing you can do whole genome
sequencing although currently this is
only viable on the Illumina platform and
potentially viable on the BGI the
Beijing genome Institute
b:g I seek 500 platform heads wins
that's commercially available it may
offer some competition one can also do
small gene panels sequencing of a
smaller thing than the genome may be a
certain number of genes involved in some
clinical disease one can do something
larger than that which is known as whole
exome sequencing and this is the
sequencing of the coding portion of the
genome in contrast to the six gigabase
genome the exome sequencing is only
38.5 megabases which is considerably
less in addition one consequence RNA
this is known as RNA feet on the
Illumina platform RNA needs to be
unknown so the Ion Torrent platform ayuh
RNA needs to be converted into cDNA and
that cDNA can be sequenced one can also
utilize these platforms for the
sequencing of methylation specifically
the 5-methylcytosine methylation and one
can best determine the sequence of the
epigenome and this can also be utilized
for something which is known as the
liquid biopsy which is getting a lot of
press and a lot of interest now whole
genome sequencing is an extremely
powerful tool to examine changes across
the genome it detects point mutations
copy number variations translocations
and deletions but there are problems
with that on the existing platform this
is before the Novus seek is made
commercially available the total cost of
a less than $1,000 is just the cost for
sequencing one still has to produce the
libraries and that's maybe a hundred
dollars or less but what about the
analysis how does one assemble that
sequence together and when one does what
do all the racers outside the coding
portion of the genome even mean and then
there's the important issue for
certainly in the cancer realm what if
one finds an alteration how many of
those alterations are actionable and
this is definitely the case with whole
genome sequencing for cancer but it may
also be true in other settings and then
there's the issue about turnaround time
I should mention that there is an
actually now the in the Guinness Book of
World Record the world record for
sequencing and doing whole genome
sequencing and analyzing and bringing it
back to the patient has been brought
down to a cost of 24 hours and this is a
big deal and this is now being util
condley in neonatal intensive care units
but what will it take the whole genome
sequencing to take off the first thing
is it depends on which patients are
getting whole genome sequencing are we
talking cancer care and treatment are we
talking about everybody getting Jeana
sequencing and indeed if it's going to
take off it's got to take off with the
total cost coming down library podcasts
will be considerably less than it is the
sequencing has to be at or around
hundred dollars and indeed this is
possible with the Nova see with the
three that three tera base the slow
cells in noticing the cost for a whole
genome sequencing could be two to three
hundred dollars but then analysis and
interpretation has to cost considerably
less I'm suggesting costing maybe two
hundred fifty dollars and figuring some
way so the storage of the sequence data
is one or two hundred dollars one adds
all of this up one sees that even though
the sequencing could be a hundred
dollars the total cost the whole genome
sequencing is considerably greater but
this would be the instance where you
would have whole genome sequencing at a
cost of less than a thousand dollars and
indeed if one sees the increase of
secrets output that's occurred over the
last ten years this is not an endpoint
there is the capability of it costing
considerably less my suggestion is that
when whole cost for genome sequencing
analysis and storage is 100 dollars
this will be the total transformation
and it will be very difficult to argue
why whole genome sequencing is not
utilized in all settings at first at any
disease for characterizing any types of
alterations and my suggestions of
sequencing companies is to recognize and
realize this and if they want sequencing
to be done as orders of magnitude over
what it said now that is the endpoint
they need to reach now so there are
problems with whole genome sequencing
currently as I mentioned the total cost
is greater than much greater than just
the sequencing but there is a viable
technology that exists today that
utilizes the strength of the Illumina
sequencing platform and this is known as
may pair suit next-generation sequencing
which is abbreviated as MPC
this is a powerful technology to analyze
to Nome on the Illumina platform one
breaks the genomes into
three to five kilobase pieces bias and a
label in the ends and then circular
izing those fragments and then if one
breaks the circulars right into small
pieces and just captures the two ends
you can basically do paired-end
sequencing of the two ends and basically
then do libraries to do parent in
sequence and this is illustrated on this
slide
DNA is isolated and fragmented one side
selects the fragments to a specific size
on the Illumina platform they utilize
five kilobase fragments they put biotin
at the end when circularize distal
molecules this is a low efficiency
reaction but the circularize molecules
are immune to endonucleases which would
digest away any of their linear
fragments so one is less just with
circularized fragments if one
circularized DNA is one fragments that
the fragment that has the two by ten
ends can be purified from all the other
fragments with streptavidin coded
magnetic beads one selects those
fragments and they're suitable substrate
for paired-end next generation sequences
one does the secret be enough fragments
on a next-generation sequencer and
aligns those sequences to the reference
genome for example if this is done on
the yield into the human genome one
generates this one to two hundred base
pairs of sequencing from the ends of
these mayfair fragments but these
fragments were originally five kilobases
apart so that even though you've done
only there's two hundred bases of
sequence for these fragments you're
actually answering the sequence of the
entire five elevations between and
without doing that sequencing and you
basically have much greater coverage
which is known as bridged coverage with
one six to one tenth of the lane on
Illumina it depends of the
next-generation machine it will be one
fiftieth of the lane one can generate 7x
coverage of a channel and with this one
can then characterize that you know
where as it takes a hundred Giga bases
of sequence to completely sequence a
human genome with whole genome
sequencing with five Giga bases of
sequencing one can cover the entire
genome with MPC this does not produce
the sequence of every nucleotide but
still characterizes the genome
characterizes alterations now at the
Mayo Clinic this has all been worked
it's been part of it's been pioneered by
dr. George was mossis who is the head of
the biomarker discovery
for a Center for individualized medicine
and working with Sarah Johnson they've
developed new algorithms to examine the
death
they've also because in some of the
cancer things that we're doing we're
very interested in viruses and viral
associations with cancer so they
contaminated all the viral genomes
together to make a new water Fisher
chromosome which they call chromosome 29
they have powerful algorithms to detect
novel junctions caused by inter and
intra chromosomal translocations and
there's a copy number variation tool
that has also been added and this is the
result of one of these types of
sequencing from the cancer that my lab
studies which is known as oropharyngeal
squamous cell carcinoma this is a cancer
at the base of the tongue and tonsils
and it is increasingly being caused by
human papilloma virus infection and is
indeed an epidemic increase in the
incidence of this cancer it is estimated
in the next couple of years the
incidence through this cancer will be
greater than the incidence of cervical
cancer and here is the sequencing I'm
actually showing at HPV integration that
is occurring to chromosome 15 the
sequences at the top are all sequences
on the chromosome 15 the sequences at
the bottom have all been into the HPV 16
genome and this is an HPV 16
integrations in the human genome and is
a human viral junction that has been
caused and the little white thing on the
bottom is actually showing the copy
number of the HPV virus which is
considerably greater than HPV just being
integrated as we can see that there's
not only HPV integration in this cancer
but still a high episomal copy number of
HPV present here is a second different
integration and this is integration into
I think chromosome 2 and one can see the
integration all the things at the top
are DNA sequences from chromosome 2
everything on the bottom is to another
HPV 16 genome and you can see this
integration and here to there's a high
copy number of HPV so HPV is not only
integrated but it's still present in
episomal copies and with this once in
characterize the physical status of a
virus and a cancer but in addition make
our sequence and characterizes changes
across the genome now in addition to
whole genome sequencing and may pair
sequencing there are also the sequencing
of small gene panels and this is perhaps
the most popular use of next-generation
sequencing in the clinic today the
strength of this includes focus on the
genes of interest and the overall cost
is considerably less and this is the
strategy that is being applied by the
Mayo Clinic but also by many other
places as well especially when one is
worried about reimbursement for the
clinical test that you are performing
now in order to capture either a small
gene panel or even the XO one needs to
do some type of enrichment for the
specific fragments one very viable one
and actually there are a number
commercially available is sure select
which is a technology that is currently
employed by Agilent and one utilizes
basically by attenuated base for the
sequences that you want to pull down you
take the genomic DNA on the top left
fragment it and put PCR primers on the
ends of it so that when you purified
hybridize fragments you can PCR amplify
them so one has these five simulated DNA
base that is mixed together with the
whole genome and you can purify it's
basically fishing you can purify the
fragments you want you then purify those
out which streptavidin coded magnetic
beads which bind to the bio simulated
baits
you've been pull those out PCR amplify
and the DNA fragments are then ready for
sequencing so the applications of
clinical NGS and I show something that's
actually from hereditary colorectal
cancer where traditionally with Sanger
sequencing one life sequence for example
the mlh1 gene there are more than one
gene that's involved in this so one
could do mlh1 msh2 n f-86 and other
things and then add more and more genes
and one should get away from a single
gene you suddenly realize that the cost
for doing a gene by gene with Sanger
sequencing becomes very expensive one
might as well adopt next-generation
sequencing once you get over five genes
it's so much cheaper to do it that way
and then you have the flexibility of
doing
1g5 genes ten genes whole exome this
would be the 20,000 human genes our
ultimately whole genome sequences that
whole exome sequencing is considerably
cheaper
and easier than whole genome sequencing
one has baits for 38.5 megabases of the
genome which is called the XO there's
also something known as the expanded
exome which has additional sequences in
a couple of non-coding transcripts and
this is the only system megabases the
advantage of this over whole genome
sequencing again is that it's cheaper
and there's much less stuff to analyze
much less stuff to store and whole exome
sequencing is currently being employed
by Washington University instead of use
small gene panels and the real
realization is the overall cost is not
much that much greater than a small gene
panel this provides comprehensive exome
information and it helps to build
databases for the future but there is
the current issue of reimbursement for
that which is one of the reasons that a
number of places including the Mayo
Clinic are still focused on the smaller
gene panels RNA seek is also a powerful
technique to examine what is actively
being transcribed it provides some
information on message abundance but
also provides transcript isoforms and
digital information on expression and
one can identify coding versus
non-coding transcripts in addition with
RNA seek one can context can protect
fused transcripts and indeed Mayo Clinic
is currently exploring the utilization
of RNA seek for the examination of fused
transcripts which have a number of
important clinical utilization now the
clinical applications currently genomic
help for their aspects to determine the
base of the Oncotype DX utilizes real
time the heart to PCR dementia gene
expression for their assays but with RNA
seek be a better alternative more
sensitive and more accurate in addition
RNA seek complements swoll gene panels
whole exome sequencing and whole genome
sequencing because with for example
whole genome or whole exome sequencing
one can tell mutations but you don't
know if that fragment that has the said
gene that has a mutation is actually
transcribed or not so RNA see complement
these other types of things and this was
concludes my presentation of the types
of clinical applications of
next-generation sequencing and was very
exciting about this is how quickly this
is being you
the lies in the clinic and we'll
definitely be transforming clinical care
thank you for your attention
Thank You dr. Smith for your informative
presentation a Cooper binder for our
audience on how to submit questions
simply type them in the Q&A box found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
dr. Smith will answer as many questions
as time permits so that further ado
let's hop in and start asking a couple
questions
our first question of the day at white
is a whole genome sequencing utilized
more routinely in clinical practice
there are a number of reasons why whole
genome sequencing is not used more
routinely in the same way that whole
exome sequencing is still a little too
expensive and the issue about
reimbursement the total cost of whole
genome sequencing is considerably
greater than just the cost of the
sequencing since one has to assemble the
sequence together one has to annotate it
one has to interpret it and more
importantly one has to store that
sequence other limitations are the fact
that when one does whole genome
sequencing really less than two percent
of the genome is the coding portion of
the genome so what is the importance of
characterizing changes outside of that
important region of the genome all of
these things are limitations this is the
main reason why with the notable
exception of the neonatal intensive care
units for diagnosing what is wrong with
a new board we're not seeing much
clinical adoption of whole genome
sequencing yet but indeed with
improvements of the overall cost of
sequencing I believe that we're going to
start to see whole genome sequencing
take off within the next few years
thank you for that answer
our second question of the day at how
can we get to the 100 dollar genome and
beyond that is an excellent question
what's the Novus shake 6000 we have the
capability yet the current cost for
reagents when the 3 tera base flow cell
is available that the cost for the
genome sequencing could be as low or
less than $300 however once meet further
improvements one has to bring the cost
of whole genome sequencing down to 100
dollars my suggestion that if the
company like Illumina decreases the
reagent cost to bring it to $100.00 and
then if the cost of the other components
for example library preparation analysis
and storage are decrease one has the
total cost of less than $1,000 however
even more improvement if more
improvements could be made greater
output so that sequencing your cost even
less then we could start to see an
approach towards a hundred dollar genome
my suggestion to all sequencing
providers is that they should reach for
that target because when genome
sequencing analysis and everything costs
$100 we will have sequencing of almost
every person on the planet and that is
the true revolution
thank you for that answer our next
question asks what are the limitations
that empty seek that is an excellent
question
while NP sake is a very strong viable
alternative to whole genome sequencing
like whole genome sequencing
it requires DNA fragments that are of a
sufficient actually empty sequel area is
even larger DNA fragment when one does
MPC it is essential that one utilizes
DNA which has not been stored in
paraffin so FFPE samples are not a
viable solution and this is a serious
problem because paraffin ization of
samples is what is routinely done
clinically so empty seeds will require a
change in clinical practice away from
from formalin fixation and indeed if and
one wants to do any type of metrics and
sequencing of whole genome sequencing
for example or MPC one is going to have
to change clinical practice and until
that is done this isn't going to be a
viable platform
excellent thank you so much for that
answer it looks as let me have one more
question our final question of the day
asks what about storage of data what
does that cost and what are the
potential solution this is the true
black box of whole genome sequencing
when one does a test at the Mayo Clinic
we have to store that data for 20 years
and I'm not even sure what is the total
cost for storing the whole genome
sequence for that much time so we either
need solutions we're only a fraction of
the data is stored or and this was was
originally made and it's not a joke the
thought they one should do the
sequencing and not store the data at all
which store the libraries and then we'll
months to do it again in the future one
can do it set but this is an issue and
this is a serious problem this is
something that needs much more focus it
used to be that one of the key
bottlenecks of whole next-generation
sequencing with that analysis and while
that still is somewhat of an issue the
question of data storage is a problem
and we need more viable solutions I've
heard of a number of places that are
trying to figure ways to store a
fraction of data you'll need the whole
genome you just need the alterations in
that you know and that is something that
is currently be developed but again if
we say what is the cost for sequencing
the genome one has to factor everything
in and not if one cannot ignore the
storage of that data and we need some
viable solutions for that before whole
genome sequencing can be done routinely
thank you
I would like to once again thank dr.
Smith for his presentation and today do
you have any final comments you'd like
to rebut with today actually I do I just
want to say that next generation
sequencing represents a very important
singularity this is a term which is coin
from Vernor Vinge and science fiction
but is the technological developments
which completely transforms the world
and next-generation sequencing is that
singularity I've had my own laboratory
for thirty years I am an expert on new
and evolving technologies but no
technology that I've seen offers the
capability of total transformation of
both the research and the clinical space
so I advise everyone to become aware of
this technology and hold on to your
seats because this technology will
transform everything thank you
thank you again dr. Smith
I'd like to thank the audience as well
for joining us today and for in pink lab
roots for today's educational webcast
this webcast can be viewed on-demand
through May 2017 libraries will alert
you via email when it's available for
replay we encourage you to share that
email with your colleagues who may have
missed today's live event this is
Christina from libraries calm we hope to
see you here next time goodbye